Acting is a serious craft.
Long before the cameras start rolling, most
great actors prepare for their roles by memorizing
lines and conducting exhaustive research,
while striving to perfect every mannerism
of the subject.
Sometimes, though, this extensive preparation
comes at a cost.
Which actors went to surprising extremes and
almost died preparing for their roles?
Was the price they paid really worth it?
We'll let you be the judge.
Matthew McConaughey
Following a string of fluffy rom-coms in the
late 2000s, it was pretty hard to take Matthew
McConaughey seriously.
"Dazed and confused is the one thing that
was passable... after that"
"Aw, thanks man, that actually launched my
career."
"After that, everything else was awful."
McConaughey managed to reignite his career
with a run of critically acclaimed movies
which culminated in an Oscar win for his star
turn in Dallas Buyers Club.
However, it turns out that the actor's Oscar
win very nearly cost him his sight.
After dropping 38 pounds to play someone suffering
from AIDS, McConaughey started experiencing
problems with his vision and consulted doctors
for medical help.
Fortunately, the effects weren't permanent,
although McConaughey did reveal to Metro that
the extreme stress he put his body through
was still affecting his sight over a year
later.
If McConaughey had continued down the dangerous
path of self-imposed starvation, it's likely
that the effects could have been even more
dangerous.
Johnny Depp
Fear & Loathing in Las Vegas represents an
interesting turning point in Johnny Depp's
career, and not just because he could have
exploded, literally, at any point.
Months before filming began, author Hunter
S. Thompson allowed Depp to live in his basement
to prepare for the adaptation.
During his time in the house, Depp taped conversations,
smoked cigarettes, and even wore Thompson's
old clothes.
The star has since shared fond memories of
this time.
"As he got closer I realized he had a three-foot
cattle prod in his left hand, and a taser
in his right hand."
Yeah, hee hee, just tryin' to make friends."
However, Thompson's act of generosity could
have led to Depp's untimely death.
After a few days, Depp discovered something
terrifying: the cigarettes he'd been smoking
in the basement could have blown the house
sky high, thanks to the gunpowder keg stored
down in the basement beside him.
"This is a very ominous assignment, with overtones
of extreme personal danger.
Occupational journalism man.
This is important Goddammit!"
Daniel Day-Lewis
Though now retired, Daniel Day-Lewis is the
poster child for modern method acting, taking
extreme measures to prepare for every movie
he stars in, from refusing to leave his wheelchair
while filming My Left Foot, to living on prison
rations for In The Name Of The Father?
Surprisingly, the most dangerous preparation
that Day-Lewis made for a role actually sounds
relatively safe.
While playing the part of Bill the Butcher
in Martin Scorsese's Gangs of New York, Lewis
simply refused to wear a warm coat while walking
around the wintry streets of New York.
Why?
The poor 19th century character he was playing
would have never owned such a luxury.
Unsurprisingly, the threadbare coat he sported
didn't do much to keep him warm, and Lewis
caught pneumonia.
He even initially refused treatment because
the medicine wouldn't have been period appropriate.
Talk about committing to a role.
"This is a night for Americans!"
Martin Lawrence
Comedians always need to have a joke or two
up their sleeve, but the real challenge of
comedy lies in the physicality of the performance.
Martin Lawrence learned this lesson all too
well following his part in Big Momma's House.
To prepare for the latex fat suit that the
role of Big Momma would require him to wear,
Lawrence decided to jog wearing heavy clothing
and a plastic suit in 100-degree heat.
At the end of his ill-fated run, Lawrence
collapsed due to extreme dehydration and heat
exhaustion.
When he first arrived at the hospital, his
body temperature hit a startling 107 degrees
and a ventilator was required to help him
breathe after he slipped into a coma that
lasted for three days.
Lawrence's attending physicians initially
feared that there might be permanent brain
damage, but Lawrence would make a full recovery.
"Is that all you got?
Well ya'll better get ready to sit down cause
you ain't gonna last long once we get all
in here.
Ain't that right?"
Matt Damon
For his role in the 1996 movie Courage Under
Fire, Matt Damon took desperate measures and
underwent an extreme diet to play a former
soldier traumatized by the effects of war.
Damon's character had become addicted to heroin,
so Damon lost 40 pounds in order to portray
the toll that would take on the human body.
Unfortunately for Damon, his strict diet took
a toll on his health in real life, too.
For months after filming ended, the star had
to remain under strict medical supervision
and take medication for the damage he'd inflicted
on his adrenal gland.
The young actor later revealed in an Reddit
AMA that he regretted his methods and was
even told by a doctor that undergoing the
unsupervised diet could have permanently shrunk
his heart if he'd continued much longer.
Ashton Kutcher
Eager to prove himself as a serious actor,
Ashton Kutcher took on the role of American
entrepreneur Steve Jobs in the 2013 bio-pic,
Jobs.
Speaking after the premiere screening at Sundance,
Kutcher told the audience he felt close to
the film's subject.
To prepare for this part, Kutcher grew his
hair long and spent hours studying tapes of
the Apple CEO in action to help him replicate
his various mannerisms.
It turns out that wasn't enough.
Before filming, Kutcher also decided to replicate
his subject's diet and only ate fruit, nuts,
and seeds.
While this might sound healthy in theory,
Kutcher wound up hospitalized for pancreatitis
just a few days before shooting began.
Kutcher's not exaggerating when he says the
experience was absolutely terrifying, but
luckily, the actor made a full recovery.
Hilary Swank
It's not unusual for actors working on fight
movies to suffer from painful injuries, but
Hilary Swank endured a more dangerous wound
than most while preparing for Million Dollar
Baby—and it all started with a simple blister.
As a result of having to pivot on her feet
constantly during training, Swank developed
a blister on her right foot which she claimed
was the size of her palm.
During an interview with correspondent Mike
Wallace for 60 Minutes, Swank explained how
it became impossible for her to train or walk
on the blister, so she popped it herself,
which led to a dangerous staph infection that
could have been fatal if left untreated.
"Don't come crying to me if you get hurt,
alrighty?"
"We got a deal."
Robert De Niro
There's more where that came from when it
comes to boxing movies that injured their
stars.
Now regarded as a masterpiece of filmmaking
and one of Martin Scorsese's best movies,
Raging Bull suffered a number of setbacks
during production that could have knocked
the film out of the running before it even
got started.
Actor Robert De Niro transformed himself for
the role of Jake La Motta, training for nearly
a year to embody the part of a real-life boxer.
During training, he boxed around 1,000 rounds
in a gym to add 20 pounds of muscle to his
frame, and even broke his mentor's rib along
the way.
However, when production in LA was completed,
De Niro was sent to Europe on an eating spree,
as the role required him to gain weight so
he could play La Motta on the decline too.
After gaining 60 pounds over a period of four
months, De Niro returned to New York to finish
filming, but the weight gain came at a price.
After his star showed signs of struggling
with his posture, breathing and even talking,
Scorsese decided to temporarily halt production,
as he believed De Niro might be at risk of
a heart attack.
"You want your steak?"
Bring it over.
It's like a piece of charcoal, bring it over
here!"
"You want your steak?"
"Yeah!"
Christian Bale
Brad Anderson's disturbing thriller was lauded
for its fascinating insight into paranoia
and delusion, but ultimately, The Machinist
will always be remembered most vividly for
Christian Bale's jaw-dropping performance.
To play the part of a man suffering from insomnia
and other serious psychological problems,
Christian Bale dropped over 60 pounds, reducing
his body mass to just 120 pounds.
During a Reddit AMA, co-star Michael Ironside
revealed an even more disturbing insight into
the dangerous extremes that Bale's diet took,
explaining how starvation had ravaged his
body, saying,
"[Chris] said, 'Can you look at this?'
And he turned and dropped his overalls [...] and
the muscles in his ass had literally dropped
out of the sockets of his hips."
As if that wasn't dangerous enough, Bale only
had six weeks to regain his normal weight
before putting on the cape and cowl for his
Batman Begins screen test, and then just five
months more to develop a physique worthy of
the caped crusader.
According to Ironside though, he didn't seem
to have much trouble managing it.
"It's not who I am underneath, but what I
do that defines me."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!